what is up my name
i am so excited today because we're
playing finally
the well delayed south park the
fractured bart home
the first one we played on this channel
it was amazing it was a daily let's play
series and finally we're back with some
video games on this channel i'm so
excited for this
i'm so excited that if this video gets
million no just 500 000 likes i will
upload part two
right away to show how committed i am to
this series that's right i'm that kind
of youtuber right now
i don't know i'm just really excited for
this and i look forward to sharing this
with you gross gross whatever
every single day it's gonna be awesome
from what i've seen so far heck yeah
let's just let's just begin
okay let's just do this if you're having
trouble winning in combat try a better
game is that what it said
never fart on someone's balls this is
really good
info on the loading screen i'm not glad
they are
i'm glad they added that as well
oh yeah so the game is getting terrible
reviews right now on
steam because ubisoft have their uplay
feature
feature uh which apparently is like a
big hiccup
i'm glad for once actually i played on
the playstation because
probably won't require good hardware
to run this i don't think it's the kind
of game that pushes the boundaries
of video game graphics but it does look
good
i play the demo it was really fun they
may
they made a whole thing about the farts
in the game which i'm very excited about
that's a nice looking cat right there
what has become of this city
cram is out of control cats are missing
and townspeople are being victimized
oh hey who pooped on my paw what's going
on with you we were supposed to protect
those who couldn't protect themselves
get off my car you little pecker now
superheroes are torn apart by
political differences
we are two sides at war
[Music]
but war isn't going to save our city
time travel i wonder if they will
explore any political
myths television ah satire when a new
king united a kingdom
torn apart by a powerful stick
hi hun shut up man there's no time to
waste
i have to go back change the present if
i can
find his cat and in doing so perhaps i
can change what has happened to all of
us
hey
[Music]
look at that
so first game was sort of lord of the
rings inspired
i guess this time they're going
superhero they're making fun of all the
netflix shows
all the franchises with marvel versus dc
all right we're gonna make our character
here we're gonna obviously go
i don't know what the heck man
ah i can change color as well okay
okay that was all options
you know we're gonna go with a big afro
there she is heck yeah man
all right we got our hair makeup
we gotta get those uh kawaii kawaii
i i those blush cheeks
oh senpai kawaii disney oh
you better believe it boy
[ __ ] there that's a
that's very nice no no no glasses
all right what do we got close why don't
we go with a classic red cape
oh we can change this as well why don't
okay let's go
uh yeah japanese school girl that's it
hands then
now red okay
i'm pretty happy
actually
there's our kawaii queen choose
difficulty all right
oh oh oh
don't worry this doesn't affect combat
just every other aspect of your whole
[Music]
life
here's the problem i don't want to i
don't want to be black i know that
sounds racist
i mean
let's go slightly this is so annoying
why
they have to do this you know what
[ __ ] it
oh my god
yes ancient zara and thank you for the
paris font
[Music]
you got to stop
who's the king oh heck yeah
man we look good see i play this this is
amazing you gotta tune in your
[ __ ]
this is just like pooping in real life
i feel like that was a terrible poop i
don't know what i did wrong
yeah master sergeant douche master
incredible we got a bottle of glass gas
bieber
gas begun what is happening out there
okay let's go we should be happy that
he's made friends in this town so
quickly
we came here to hide more friends just
means more trouble
you're being paranoid you need to lay
off that stuff it's changing you
oh lay off it's the one thing that helps
me relax from your stupid [ __ ]
oh hey whippersnapper didn't see you
there
your friends are downstairs kiddo get
out there and play
this is great so far they really
polished it up oh is he gonna masturbate
or
smoke pot he's gonna smoke okay
no he's just eating brownies just
brownies am i right kids
okay this is our room this is a nice
room for a
kids
wow
what the heck is that dude
i'm just trying to explore because i
remember inside the first game it was
always like
glad we updated that thing maybe we
should keep it on keep it up
where's the fart button there it is
found it
never gets old that's it okay let's go
down checking our friends
i love our character it's so beautiful
[Music]
i had this whole arc written for him
what up mom mommy stop crying sweetheart
i just have something stuck in my eyes
well i don't care i'm just trying to
loot all right
i thought you said my friends were
downstairs lying
run the door my lord the filthy maurice
are attempting to overtake koopa keep
you guys in fight my leaves you're our
only hope
okay we're gonna get some combat
um it seems like they improved it a lot
this time around like you can actually
move around and stuff doing this
which doesn't sound that exciting but
i'm told that it's really good brad has
been playing a little bit as well what
you just moved to town
and you get to be king well i think
you're a little [ __ ] i agree why do i
have to be
start a fight by punching oh okay cool
[ __ ]
combat advantage okay cool because we
started
is that a shark pond oh we changed the
rules a little bit since yesterday
okay before you can hit him okay
okay all right use my power
very nice yeah double
heck yeah powers with knockback cause
extra damage
uh okay i got that you're not stamina
i'm not afraid of you in your strategic
king combos
oh man is it still up to me okay
uh all right i will
good well that was easy i thought we
were playing
on hard mode we can't stop him ready the
guards of the dark court
did you see that
got the kung fu kawaii fist these guys
look
tougher okay we're gonna fight as a team
now probably
no it's me versus everyone attacking an
enemy first friends who cometh invention
yeah okay see the full combat turn order
check the timeline okay
uh different powers okay review power
okay
[Music]
we can fart i don't know what that does
why don't we try a fart here maybe that
will hit all of them oh okay it hits
three squares got it
okay all right let's do that
[Music]
oh my god oh the humanity that was
amazing
go king did this hate me with a stop
sign oh it's an axe
you can't keep the moors down
yeah they improve the combat even
further since i played it this is really
dope
so i can't use the fart again i gotta
wait one round uh what's the best
who's the most dead uh
all right i guess i'll punch you got him
there it is got all of them the kawaii
king
hail to the quebec
all right let's keep moving
those legos we're going through that
door you can't
oh yeah why not because everything in
front of here is lava
oh dude no way all that is lava yeah
everything from here to here is lava you
can't pass it
[ __ ] come on let's get inside we can't
they're seeing everything in front of
the tourist lava
wow that's not fair what do we do the
king what do you do now
you die release the dragon
oh my god
okay so they attacked us first now
that's the dragon roaring enemies may
attempt to attack you while you explore
okay yeah if an anime man boosts you
you'll
okay i got that yes
okay we have a new let's just
will that attack the dragon you know
let's just try
yeah okay work nice
nice
oh okay he has fire breath striped red
squares indicate damage zone okay now i
got that too
it's very self-explanatory oh you have
to move okay
[Laughter]
just like playing street when you're a
kid
was he taking his phone
it reminds me of wayne's word
i can't reach him are you serious
okay now i can there we go
take whoa
damn dog
king douchebag dragon slayer heck yeah
man
[Music]
king douchebag not too bad not too
shabby oh my god he defeated the dragon
they'll freaking way that kid's amazing
you know it son you know what what up
where's my puss
okay we can open the box
oh my god maybe there's a way in through
the garage get off my dick there's a way
in through the garage
the king will find it press and hold to
move objects
in through the garage if i mean if there
is one
yes only the king king news bag is such
a skeleton oh my god get up see how we
move that letter and use it
oh my god
oh i missed it i thought the king was
going to do a sweet jump but then he
just did that
what you're
dead it's so cheesy i hit it i swear i
hit it
all right whatever speak bard what
happened to the stick of truth
the wizard had it thrown into the ocean
wow oh yeah that was the end of the
first game
unhand him you heathens release the
portal you'll have the king to deal with
the king they say he can slay a dragon
with one blow
that's right and if you don't wait wait
whoa where is the wizard
uh i thought he was with you guys now we
got a distress signal to come help him
here
the wizard is down my name is the king
i'm from the future dude we said we're
not playing that anymore
yeah they're all split up what's the
point this is the point
in my time there is a massive crime wave
and missing cats
i knew my only hope was to assemble the
team hey you can't switch games like
this where's the stick of truth
shut up kevin this isn't about some dumb
stick there's a cat in trouble
and it's the key to finding the crime
syndicate new to our town in the future
i'm said to kiss that that sounds too
heavy for kunis red well what do you
want clyde you want the [ __ ] freedom
palace to find the missing cat
get the hundred dollar reward and make
their superhero franchise more popular
[ __ ] the freedom house dude
that's right poopsickins there's a loud
ringing coming from your basement
playroom
the [ __ ] alert come on [ __ ] friends go
get your stuff and report back to the
[ __ ] lair
in the future sorry guys you can't play
with us we're playing superheroes now
and you guys are dorks
what about me oh oh
nice transition from uh their first game
to this one
can we talk to these guys see what they
say well nothing left to do but go home
and play star trek bridge crew
we could all go to my house and sit
around nice nice little self promo there
ubisoft i see what you're doing
i've been thinking about joining a gang
this might be just the kick in the pants
i need that is a good game though to be
fair so i'll let it slide
oh hello the boys are down in their
little basement playroom
can i slap that ass eric and his friends
are so
imaginative really
really i know you're into weird [ __ ]
take
all and continue [ __ ] cakes okay
oh yeah i remember this there's a
passcode we have
oh did you get locked out i'm afraid
little eric put a lock on the door to
keep me out
i'm sure he has the passcode written
down here somewhere well it's probably
in his room then
so let's go upstairs and check it out
what is that what is that now
that sounded just like a real cat wow
[Music]
that is the most annoying cat ever wow
wow meow all right we're in cartman's
room
here's the who is the king dame driver
there must be a ton of references in
here i think i said
there's an oculus in there i see that
they were they were on point with that
episode
danish as for denmark yes
2012 election um
punch what's a cracked object got some
chicken wings
why what is it telling me to oh the lamp
is cracked
we can read this journal okay all right
so
that's a great drawing of oh it's the
fan fiction
butters and i don't remember man fake
fan christmas list ideas
drone hoverboard oh
okay well he has a oh okay let's keep
key code [ __ ] you mom
no that's actually the key code or is
what no that can't be the key code
seriously okay let's go down and check
let me check all the room first
[Music]
i feel like this is the kind of game i
actually want to explore
because you know there's going to be
like secret references and stuff
and that's always fun to look for yes
officer somebody appears to have put
lava in front of my door well no
it's not oh my god my son told me i will
burn to death if i try and cross it
uh-huh oh yes he did tell me that if i
step on a crack it would break my
mother's back mom
it won't i should have played with that
word
that's not enough mosquito we have to
act fast before the freedom pals can a
hundred dollar reward
do you know what that could mean to our
superhero franchise that cat looks
pretty old
maybe he just died in the gutter
somewhere humankind do i have to remind
you that as of right now freedom pals
have a hundred followers on instagram
we have six the five of us and billy
turner who's a ginger
this is the key to finally beating those
[ __ ] but where do we start looking
that cat could be anyway we need to
split up mosquito
take to the air and check out all the
city parks you got it
mosquito away wow what a great superhero
human kite see if the cat is stuck up a
tree somewhere you've got human capital
craig
what is super great i need you to use
your superhuman speed to get to the
mayor's office and tell her we're on the
case
don't worry koon you can count on
fast pass
gray excuse me
he's selling his own merch top bad guys
professor chaos
okay nice oh yeah
hey hey do not touch that
that device can blow up the entire milky
way galaxy jesus [ __ ]
sorry um the new kid is trying to play
with the cube of ultimate destruction
you be nice to all your friends eric be
a good sharer
good shower it'll blow up the [ __ ]
galaxies stupid [ __ ]
look dude we already told you you can't
play you aren't a superhero you don't
have a costume you don't have any
superpowers
all right look you can watch us play
superheroes as long as you don't get in
the way
make yourself useful go grab those
costumes are tailored to the kin's
unique body specs
you have to be pretty buff to fit them
buff yeah that's our holding cell for
super villains why would we keep us the
furnace device in there
uh enter inspection mode to find objects
by interest by holding
l two you seriously can't find the
supremacy device
uh superheroes use inspection mode you
know
oh sorry my controller is rebinded okay
so there's something over here
we got us yeah okay
uh there's something on the table that's
cool makes it easy
can't seem to reach it i mean there's
clearly
here but what
did i just throw a fart
whoa i'm powerful oh i ordered him that
was it oh my god the friend see the best
active
[Music]
you really want to be a superhero huh
play with the big boys
yes well maybe maybe you can be useful
have a seat at the table douchebag okay
let's do this
let's see mosquitoes adls jesus christ
are these even in a human language
all right in order to play superheroes
you have to have a superhero persona
yes then you can fill out your character
sheet on coon's degree to instagram
of course who doesn't have a [ __ ]
instagram page oh boy you're not even on
instagram huh well i guess i can create
one for you i can't unbelievable let's
see
all right nice so now we get to select
what kind of superhero we want to be
since you're a newbie you can only
choose between three for now wait so i
can change later
okay we can be blaster
brutalist brutalist yes
uh close range lost speedster
blaster
[Music]
brutalist it seems like blaster is uh
all round yeah
so let's see cyclops let's do that
okay douchebag but now we need to find
out what terrible thing in your past
drives you
you see douche all superheroes have a
compelling backstory
it's from that backstory that their
powers gain meaning let's take you back
to when you were just a child
okay you lay awake that night
like so many other nights you couldn't
sleep because you knew you weren't like
the other kids
you walked to the mirror
i walked to the mirror okay got it you
looked in the mirror and you felt alone
and that's when it happened a loud noise
you swore you could hear your mother
calling for help
oh i remember this you left your room
out in the hallway you saw two intruders
no what's happening what is happening
from hurting your parents what is
happening you had the power to stop them
so for the first time you called upon
your blaster powers
what i didn't click anything
i literally just click oh that's so
annoying
okay we're here now you looked in the
mirror and you felt alone
and that's when it happened a loud noise
you swore you could hear your mother
calling for help
you left your room out in the hallway
you saw two intruders in front of your
parents door
you had to stop them from hurting your
parents you knew you had the power to
stop them
there we go
as a blazing blaster hero you began to
overheat as the fire in your belly
ignited
you wait oh yeah because this is my new
uh okay cool
we can do the burn thing let's do that
you fried the bad guy i have to do it
from here i'm stupid
oh that's cool oh my god it's the third
one gave yourself some space by knocking
your bows back
okay perfect
whoa hallie that's it but the intruders
wouldn't take getting pushed around
lightly hey you can't push us around
like that
okay there's no timing i just have to
press it i didn't really understand
okay now we have our old alt ready hot
now you little flamer
yeah we showed him you were gravely
injured but the intruder's blows only
awakened the fires that burned within
okay here we go finish them oh
it's coming from my anus i knew it
i'm glad we saw that thank you very much
now park
and so you beat them all seem to be okay
but then you finally reached your
parents door
and what you saw when you opened that
door changed your life forever
and led you to fighting crime you were
too late
because when you opened that door you
saw you saw your dad
[ __ ] your man the horror
oh my god that's a pretty heavy
backstory you fight crime because you
never forgot the night you weren't in
time
and you saw your own father the man you
trusted [ __ ] your mother the man you
trusted it's like a ripple in time you
can't ever change isn't it
all right now that you're a superhero i
have a mission yes
i need you to go out into town and try
to get as many followers as you can on
instagram it's the only way our
franchise will survive
oh my god we look terrible okay well
that's awesome
i think that will end episode there
remember five
hundred thousand is that too much i feel
like i'm asking too much i feel like you
guys can do it
let's go come on part two thank you guys
so much for watching i'm so excited to
play more of this
i'll make it the episodes longer as we
go as well and as always
bro fist squad fan